who would win in a basketball game
between Michael Jordan's 9697 Chicago
Bulls and Steph Curry and the 2015 2016
record-breaking Golden State Warriors we
can give you the answer using matths and
something called The Zed Factor The Zed
Factor uses a statistical distribution
which is called the normal distribution
so a normal distribution Maps a set of
data which has this kind of shape so we
have this bell-shaped curve sometimes
called a gaussian and if we say this is
X and this is y then the center is at
what we call me which is going to be the
mean so the average value of our
distribution peak's going to be there
most data points will be near to the
mean and then as we move away things get
less and less likely really common
example would be like height of people
in the UK because I'm in the UK now
there's an average height and then
you've got a few people who are really
small and a few people who are really
tall but most of them are grouped around
the mean and the power of the normal
dish distribution is that it amazingly
works for sets of data that you wouldn't
even begin to think it would possibly
work for and there's all kinds of
mathematical theory behind this there's
something called the central limit
theorem not going to talk about that
today but homework it's really cool
allows you to use a normal distribution
in all kinds of really interesting
situations so we've got the peak the
central bit in the middle is at the mean
and then we have a measure of the spread
called the standard deviation and we
call this Sigma so if Sigma the standard
deviation is Big the data is nice and
spread out so if I were to draw one with
a small standard deviation but the same
mean then it might look a bit more like
this okay so this one would have a
smaller Sigma smaller standard deviation
it's more clustered around that mean
whereas the one in black the standard
deviation is bigger it's more spread out
given a data set you can work out the
standard deviation there's a formula
right uh measures that the distance of
each data point from the mean when we
plot this graph for a normal
distribution we are plotting a
mathematical function it is important to
remember that this is centered on the
mean so this is not x equals not this is
centered on the average value of the
data so what's actually being plotted
here is the following we're plotting a
function of X which is rather
complicated 1 over the 2 pi uh we also
have a sigma on the bottom there and
then we do the exponential e to power of
-1 / 2 Sigma ^ 2 * x - mu^ 2 so 1 < tk2
Pi Sigma e to- x - that is that graph
where the Center is at mu and the spread
is controlled by Sigma this represents a
probability it's a statistical
distribution so the area under the curve
has to have a total of one because the
total probability is one so what this
means is if I took like a value here
let's call this X1 and if I wanted to
know what is the suppose this is height
and you know average is like 5'8 suppose
this is like 6t I wanted to know what's
the probability in the UK population of
being smaller than six foot I need to
add up all of this area up to that point
so the area under your distribution
gives you the probability you add up all
of that area that's why for the red one
I drew the peak going taller because
again the total area under it even
though it's narrower still has to be one
has to total one so if we want to know
the probability up to this point X1 we
know the total area is one so if we
wanted to know the probability that X
was less than or equal to X1 so we can
be anywhere all the way down to us
Infinity up to this X1 value we have to
integrate because that's how we find the
area under a curve we know the function
FX so we would be integrating from minus
infinity all of these values are allowed
all the way up to a maximum of X1 and we
want the area under this curve so we
integrate F
ofx between those two points key thing
key relationship is we want to work out
probability up to a certain point this
is called the CDF or the the cumulative
distribution function that's going to be
important we just simply integrate up to
this point so what it also means is if
we have the CDF if we differentiate it
the reverse of integrating we get back
this one which is called the PDF
probability density function so you
integrate or differentiate to move
between the two of
[Music]
them that's
that so what does all of this have to do
with basketball the idea is we're going
to take the data for that particular
season the number of wins or win
percentage of a team in that particular
season and we're going to try and create
a statistical distribution and this is
an assumption this is a mathematical
model but if you look at the
distribution of wins in a regular NBA
season or any other sport there's an
average number of wins that a lot of
teams are clustered around there's the
Champions who win loads down here and
there's the really bad teams who win
very few so it actually has really
really really good for most sports and
most data as long as you have a lot of
games fits really nicely into this
normal distribution model so this is
what we're going to use to allow us to
construct a distribution for each season
and then compare them so the trick is we
construct a normal distribution for the
96 997 NBA season and find you know
Chicago balls are somewhere down here we
construct a separate different normal
distribution for the Golden State
Warriors in 2015 2016 they're also
somewhere over here but how do we
compare them when they're both on
different graphs across the different
eras who knows maybe the Bulls were
playing weaker teams maybe all the other
teams were rubbish in 96 997 so who
really cared they were obviously going
to win all their games right again you
can have an opinion on this but we want
to get it down mathematically so we've
got addition two two separate
distributions for each team in each
season but what we can do is reduce each
of them to what we call the standardized
normal distribution and that then allows
us to compare what position are they on
the standard one in order to be able to
do that we need to figure out how do we
turn a general normal distribution into
the standardized one and what is the
standardized one the normal distribution
we have here with this complicated PDF
my random variable X is normally
distributed mu and variance Sigma squ so
the variance is just the standard
deviation squar now the standard normal
often referred to as Zed and this is
where I think Zed Factor comes from is a
normal distribution with mean zero and
standard deviation one so the question
now becomes how do we turn this graph
the more the most General possible
normal distribution into a n one
distribution and the way we do it is you
say Z is equal to x minus mu so we
subtract the mean away hopefully you can
see would turn this Center Point to zero
shift it xus mu shifts the graph to the
left by mu and then we divide by Sigma
so we rescale by one over Sigma so this
is the standardized normal so you take
your data point from whatever season it
might be 96 97 bulls or the 15 16 Golden
State you subtract the mean off from
that season and divide by the standard
deviation of that season and then you've
got a value of the normal not one
which allows you to actually then
compare the Zed factor and that is
exactly what the Zed factor is it's your
data point minus the average from the
whole set divided by the standard
deviation for the whole set and this is
comparing everything on the same
Distribution on the same graph and it
removes this idea of there being
different erors different strength
opponents that is all factored in
because we've reduced everything to the
standardized normal so given we have our
formula for the PDF when we have mu and
sigma squ we substitute into this
formula where Sigma is 1 and mu is zero
so what I'm going to get is going to be
1 over the < TK 2 pi Sigma disappears
because it's one we've then got the
exponential of -1/ 2 and then mu is zero
and I've called this Zed instead of X so
it just be Z squ so now if we were to
plot this it has the same shape as this
but comparing what's happened here we've
shifted it by mu and we've rescaled a
little bit by Sigma so what does this
all mean well we can take our our
distribution our data point from any
time period in history for any sport
team in any spot and we can then reduce
it to the standard normal and then get
the Zed factor and we can then compare
those values as which one is bigger in
theory You could argue says which team
is better okay so for a standard normal
and by this I mean the normal n one the
one we're reducing everything to if we
are one standard deviation away on
either side so this is plus or minus one
either side then you can work out this
probability because we know the
probability of being between these two
values is just the area underneath this
curve we know what the curve looks like
so we just integrate this between these
two values so what you will find is that
being between minus one Sigma and zero
this is 3413 sort of percent probability
this is the same 34.1 3% probability
then if we go up to next ones along
2 Sigma or minus 2 Sigma be plus two or
minus two then this adds an additional
13.59% and then we go up to 3 Sigma and
minus 3 Sigma and this will then give us
an additional 2.14 and then being beyond
that point you're actually just
0.13% we're going to be interested in
the good performers because you can do
the same for the bad ones down here
right if you're if you're in this little
tiny thing you're more than three sigma
below the average you are historic Ally
the worst team ever and we're talking
about here number of wins yes in the
season and you could also do like number
of goals number of home runs number of
three pointers you just need to make
sure that you define what it is and you
need to have a large data set that is
important so you want at least 20 data
points really um in terms of teams in
the league to be able to have 20 points
along the curve ideally 30 but most
competitions have about 20 at least when
it comes to football my favorite um I
guess you've got 30 B teams um and you
also need to have a pretty good idea of
that team's performance so for example I
did not do this for the NFL American
football because they only play 16 games
it's a very small sample size to see if
a team's actually good over 16 games but
in a 80 plus game NBA season you've got
a lot of data points there which gives
you a feel for just how good a team
actually is so once you start getting
above two Sigma beyond the average
you're really seeing something quite
rare you know that could be be I
wouldn't quite say once in a
generational but that's like you know
you're a good team you're getting above
two as your Z Factor value you are
really much you probably won the league
put it that way if you're getting a
value up there and then if you go three
and Beyond then you're greater than
99.87% data so a z factor of over three
is like a 1 in 800 team so if you've got
20 teams in the league that's like one
in 40 years so that you would argue is
very much a generational collection of
you know performance from that team or
maybe individual performance so we're
going to kind of be looking at things
from two onwards right because that's
when you're getting into like the real
good teams occasionally you will see
values above three I've never seen a
value above four despite doing this for
all kinds of different sports and
different data sets but once you there
are a few of them that go above three um
which tend to be one example that comes
to mind was Pelle Brazilian football
player he had a season when he scored
like 70 something goals in in like 20
League games which is clearly ridiculous
and that was like 3.8 on on the Zed
Factor so again regardless of his
competition that was just a once in a
century level of performance so you do
sometimes see those but this is the
setup we're interested in what is this
Zed value and the bigger it is the sort
of more of an outlier that particular
team is so we started asking the
question Michael Jordan's Bulls Steph
Curry Golden State so took the best SE
of both of them the Bulls in
9697 had a zed factor of
2.06 very very good for sure the Golden
State Warriors had a zed factor in 2015
2016 which is when they set the league
record for the most wins in a regular
season that came out at 2.54 you know
we're going to interpret this as who
would win in a match I think the the
maths would tell you Golden State of
2015 2016 were more
dominant compared to Chicago blls of
9697 but this doesn't take into account
many many things obviously the way the
teams match up uh the way the teams
perform under certain conditions but it
also doesn't take into account how much
they won their games by the Chicago
Bulls could have won every game by 40
points and the Warriors squeaked a few
by one or two points oh absolutely so
there's there's a very good question and
a very interesting point you raised
because the
201617 Golden State Warriors are by many
basketball analysts deemed to be better
because the 15 16 team actually lost in
the championship game right whereas
obviously the Bulls won so even though
they set the regular season record they
lost when it mattered right the one game
you want to win they ended up losing or
best of seven games well yeah yeah they
lost it 4 three yeah um to to Cleveland
it was but the year after um the 2016 17
they won it and also in that season they
I think set the record record for the
most points they won on average by it
was over 10 points with their average
Victory so the
167 could be argued how we're a stronger
team but their Zed Factor actually lower
because they won fewer games across the
season it's a really important point
about all of Statistics is what data did
I use to draw this conclusion so you
know me saying this means Golden State
would beat Michael Jordan's blls I don't
know that I'm just saying based on how
many wins each of those teams had at
their peak season you know their their
know highest winning season the Golden
State Warriors from a mathematical
perspective that was more of an outlier
than the the number of wins the Bulls
managed so you can't really use it to
conclude who would win right I was kind
of joking a little bit when I said that
but we do have a measure that argues it
was more impressive it was a rarer event
for the golden State Warriors to win
that many games in 2015 2016 and that
does take into account the level of
competition than it was for the Bulls
and their winning record in in 9697 I
guess the the Holy Grail of sports
statistics and I know this is often sort
is to come up with one number or figure
that encapsulates the strength and how
good a team is but then you would take
that across the generations and use this
method to compare Generations absolutely
yeah the the question might be then what
is the
suitable number or suitable data set to
compare teams across eras I've just used
win number of wins win percentage
because it seemed the most
straightforward That's What sport's
about yeah ultimately that is what sport
is about but then yeah so because you
know because people would argue it's the
number of titles you win it's the number
of trophies or versus you know who cares
if you won the league and then lost the
title game no one cares is some people's
opinion but I just based this on wins
because that allowed me to compare win
percentage across different sports so
we've been focusing on basketball but I
have Z factors for other sports and
other teams across different eras
Liverpool 2020 finally won the league
after a long wait Premier League
football team Brady's a Liverpool fan I
I'm not a Liverpool fan um their Zed
Factor was
2.62 which is really high so even better
higher than the Golden State one from
1516 so that was a really impressive
season from Liverpool based on level of
competition at that time um then other
famous Premier League football teams
you've got the Arsenal invincibles they
went the whole season without losing a
game the only team whoever have done
this in the Premier League and that was
a 2.53 so actually a little bit less Man
City got 100 points they were known as
the centurions in 2017 2018 that was 2.5
so again around that kind of 2.5 level
but a little bit below Liverpool and
then my my favorite team man united so
their highest Zed Factor actually
occurred in 1992 93 three so going back
to almost one of the first few or maybe
even the first year of the Premier
League when they actually had a z factor
of 2.59 still not quite as good as
Liverpool's but the interesting thing
there is that man united team lost six
games which is a lot higher than you see
in all of these other ones I've
mentioned but back in that time period
the early 90s the league was way more
condensed right so you had you kind of
had I think United won it with like 80
something and you had so many teams with
like 70 60 50 whereas take Liverpool in
2020 they were on like 99 and then it
was like 81 for Man City and then it was
like 50 40 20 20 it was just the
standard deviation here plays a part and
that's because it's comparing the
particular performance to the strength
of opposition at that time period other
ones in football that I found
interesting so I looked at La Liga in
Spain um so Real Madrid's best season
according to zed factors was 2011 2012
they scored 2.85 which is actually the
highest I found for any football team
they did score over I think they got 10
and something points 102 points that
year we also had Barcelona the year
Messi scored all the goals which is the
season after that they scored 2.66 so
again really high and then outside of
football I also looked at um
baseball I thought that would be an
interesting one because you have more
data points to play more games um so
I'll admit I'm not a huge follower of
baseball but some research online told
me that there's an argument around um
the team with the most wins so there's
the 1906 Chicago Cubs had 116 wins and
then you had the 2001 Seattle Mariners
had 116 wins which as far as I'm aware
is the record number of wins in a season
the Cubs had a higher win percentage it
was
76.3% they won more of their games
because you played fewer games in 1906
compared to 2001 however Zed factors
1906 Cubs
2.05 2001 Seattle Mariners 2.6 eight so
really big difference there in the Zed
factor which based on win percentage
alone even though the Cubs had a higher
win percentage the level of competition
the Mariners faced clearly was tougher
which meant that according to this
particular statistic of the Zed Factor
the 2001 Mariners actually were more of
an outlier than the 1906 cargo Cubs I
love this stuff I love sports statistics
you know the you know the question
that's coming into my head
is what is the lowest Zed factor a team
has won the league with Oh I thought you
were going to say like the worst team
ever no the lowest Z Factor but you
still won the league I can figure that
out you can all figure this out so we've
of course talked about started with
basketball talked about football my
favorite sport little bit on baseball
they're just the spots and as we've
discussed the win percentage number of
games won that's just the particular
data sets that I decided to apply this
Theory to the joy of this and this is a
let's call it a homework exercise for
the interested viewer to throw out to
you all is try this for yourselves pick
your favorite sport your favorite team
get the data you just need to figure out
what it is you want to measure whether
it's number of goals scored by a certain
player number of home runs
three-pointers number of wins of a team
whatever you want pick What statistic
you want to compare across different
eras different time periods get all the
data work out the mean relatively
straight forward the average value work
out the standard deviation again there's
a formula and then figure out your Z
factor it's just your data point minus
the mean divided by standard deviation
and you can figure out the Zed factor
for your favorite team in your favorite
spot and see how it compares to all of
the ones that we've looked at here you
could even compare players from
different sports Michael Jordan's threep
pointers versus Don bradman's runs
absolutely y who was who was more
exceptional that's what the Z fact is
telling you it's like how how much of a
surprise was this particular statistic
this particular performance of this
particular person check out this great
puzzle from episode sponsor Jane Street
the numbers represent the heights of
Manhattan skyscrapers and you need to
place them in a very special
configuration it's all to do with what
skyscrapers block other
ones now Jane streets are trading firm
with officers all around the world
including New York they've made this
puzzle well for fun really they love
making puzzles but it's also to draw
some attention to its upcoming Academy
of math and programming Summer Event in
New York this is a chance for recent
high school graduates who sometimes face
barriers in their education journey to
come to New York amongst the skyscrapers
with all their expenses paid and to
learn about Game Theory data analysis
programming all that good stuff now for
more details on just what a great
opportunity this is well have a look in
the video description and by the way you
don't don't need to like complete the
skyscraper puzzle to apply for this
program it's just for fun and you don't
need to be interested in the program to
just go and do the puzzle as well it's
for everyone to have a go There's the
link and there's one you can click on in
all the usual
[Music]
places